[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone
so i am super excited about this lecture
this is a new one i haven't given this
before in class but i've been meaning to
for a long time
and it's all about the wave equation
which is one of the most important
partial differential equations in all of
physics it is everywhere
and so i like to think about kind of
motivating the wave equation uh by
thinking about music and acoustics so a
guitar
or a vibrating guitar string is a really
really good example
of a wave equation that we're going to
derive and analyze and solve so this is
a two-part
lecture and in the first lecture i'm
going to motivate you know what is the
wave equation where does it come from
uh what are some examples like literally
these examples are everywhere from
acoustics to optics
uh you name it it's everywhere
and we're going to derive this wave
equation from scratch from first
principles physics and then tie it back
to some intuitive examples like a
vibrating guitar string so we're going
to ask questions like
you know why does tensioning the guitar
string making it you know more more
tension make it a higher pitch sound
versus a lower pitch sound
things like that uh why are the thinner
guitar strings higher
than the thicker guitar strings
you know why does changing the material
from let's say steel to to nylon change
things that's all uh kind of an outfall
of the wave equation so i'm going to
come back to this in a little bit and
for right now i'm going to
start by kind of deriving and explaining
what i mean by the wave equation
good
so maybe i'll use some colors here so
the idea uh of this this wave equation
is that you have i'm just going to write
down the equation u t t
equals c squared
u x x
where u is going to be the height of
some string so we're going to assume
that we have uh
a string
that is pinned
let's say
between
two locations so this is going to be the
x equals zero location and this is going
to be the x equals l location so that's
the length of my guitar string in this
case
and what we're assuming there's some
like rest position where the string is
just you know under some tension but
it's not moving and we're defining u
to be the height or the displacement of
this guitar string from that rest
position
so these are all my
uh u
of x
and t
okay so the the displacement of that
string is a function of of its position
spatially along the length of that
string and it also changes in time you
can picture this thing literally you
know kind of oscillating um you know the
good the guitar string is oscillating
and that's what's creating these
acoustic waves
so that's one example
of the wave equation is something like a
vibrating string
this is where the boundary conditions
are pinned so that both the x equals
zero and x equals l boundaries are
pinned to be zero displacement
um i think it's actually really
interesting that the acoustic waves that
this vibrating string generates these
acoustic waves that you're hearing from
from me talking or from that guitar
string vibrating those also satisfy
this uh linear wave equation so even
though acoustic waves are pressure waves
traveling through a fluid medium and we
know fluids are governed by the
non-linear navier-stokes equations
acoustic waves are kind of infinitesimal
uh
infinitesimal shock waves if you like
they're traveling at the speed of sound
in the in the medium whether it's air or
water or helium
and
those those pressure waves those shock
waves are infinitesimal so that they
don't create
any
kind of noticeable change in entropy as
they travel which is why acoustic waves
travel such great distances that's why
you can hear
you know an airplane flying overhead
from great distances things like that
okay
i should mention that this c here is the
wave speed so maybe i'll just make note
of that so c
equals
let's say the wave speed
um
and if if we're talking about acoustic
waves this would be the speed of sound
in the fluid medium
if we're talking about optics this would
be the speed of light
in a given a given medium so that's
another example is optics okay so if i
have let's say this is my eye
and i have light coming in you know from
some source
and bending through
my the optics of my eye to hit my retina
these plane waves from maxwell's
equations from electromagnetism
those are also governed by the linear
uh second order wave equation okay
where you know the second derivative of
this uh
fluctuation whatever that fluctuating
quantity is in time is equal to the wave
speed squared times its fluctuations the
second derivative of those fluctuations
in space
so optics acoustics vibrating strings
all of these are governed by the wave
equation
i had the guitar string which is pinned
in two places
but if you also have something like
let's say i have
i think every kid has done this when
they were you know young you take a rope
and you flick the rope and you send a
traveling wave down that rope so maybe
it goes in this direction
in that case the boundary conditions are
a little bit different than the guitar
string so
now one of my boundary conditions my
hand is forcing it at some profile in
time and then the other boundary
condition if it's a very very long rope
you would assume is kind of uh you know
unpinned or free and so you get
different solutions to those uh those
wave equations but they're still
governed by the same physics whether
depending uh on on the boundary
conditions
uh what are some other examples um some
of you like to slackline i'm pretty sure
and so if you take a tree
let's say you have a cool tree
and you have your slack line set up
around this tree
and you are a human
on this slack line
and so if you're anything like me you're
probably
vibrating a little bit
uh and then also the string the kind of
um
the cable that's connecting there's
another tree over here that's uh
connected to the other side
this
cable is also vibrating at some
frequency
and so we're going to be able to
understand so we're going to derive this
wave equation we're going to see how
this speed of the wave the wave speed at
least in the guitar string and this
slack line depend on things like the
tension in the rope or the tension in
the string the thickness or material
properties of that string
those are all going to
kind of go into this this wave speed c
but these are just some of the many many
many examples of how the wave equation
comes up in physics and in engineering i
guess you know i also think about if you
throw a rock in a pond you're going to
get you know some kind of ripple effect
in that pond
you know that's also going to travel uh
according to this this wave equation uh
with some some uh assumptions
and simplifications okay good so i'm
going to start
deriving this wave equation i'm going to
specifically derive it for
uh this kind of guitar string because
that for me is very intuitive
and then we're going to analyze the
properties
of of this equation and understand how
kind of the physics and the math tie
together
so something i like to also point out is
a little bit of the history of this wave
equation so
this wave equation in 1d as a partial
differential equation
was written down by dallam bear i think
in 1746
this was not the first time that a
vibrating string was mathematically
considered that was done earlier
by
what
brook taylor okay so that was
you know a decent bit earlier
uh kind of right after newton's f equals
m a brook taylor started analyzing
vibrating strings
but the partial differential equation
was written down by dahlember in 1746
and then about 10 years later euler
generalized this to a full
three-dimensional wave equation so in 2d
you can think of the membrane of a drum
as a two-dimensional wave equation in
three dimensions uh euler generalized
this so that would be like acoustic
waves in three space traveling in all
directions
uh and i guess in that case this u x x
would be replaced by a laplacian of u
operator okay which we've seen before in
our other examples of partial
differential equations
good okay um
so i think i'm going to jump into this
thing so this is the uh the definition
of what i mean by my variable u it is
the height of my guitar string
it could also be the the kind of
amplitude of my pressure you know wave
if i'm talking about acoustics um
there's different you know meanings of
you and all of these different physical
scenarios but for here i'm going to zoom
in on this guitar string and just think
about that
and
and so what we're going to do is try to
derive this equation here from scratch
and so what i like to think about is
at the end of the day the the wave
equation is actually one of the simplest
equations to derive uh in physics
because it really is just
f equals m a it is the conservation of
momentum
in this kind of elastic springy medium
now this is kind of a meaningful lecture
for me because
it actually took me a really long time
in my mathematical career to feel
comfortable and confident kind of
deriving and analyzing the wave equation
from scratch
so you know i loved calculus and
differential equations when i was a kid
and i remember saving up
my money when i was you know a teenager
to buy this differential equations book
it was the one differential equations
book
that barnes and noble sold it was a
really really good book
and i remember working through kind of
the ordinary differential equations and
i got to the section on partial
differential equations
and it started with the wave equation
and the derivation of the wave equation
always confused me and i just got stuck
time and time again you know on two
pages in to this section on partial
differential equations and eventually i
just kind of left it and didn't really
revisit partial differential equations
until i was a grad student
and so years later now that i'm teaching
this material i think it's really
important you know to be able to derive
these things from scratch to really
physically understand how they're tied
to simple concepts like f equals ma and
conservation and i just kind of want to
demystify how this is derived and
analyzed because for me
uh you know this was kind of a mental
block and i'm telling you this because
you know a lot of you see me derive
these things and it looks easy and you
don't maybe know that this took
in this case decades for me to really
feel comfortable uh with this derivation
and also with kind of all the physical
interpretations and how to really
uh kind of manipulate this equation and
understand how it relates to things like
a guitar string or a slack line and
things like that
good
so
f equals m a and what we're going to do
is we're going to zoom in on a little uh
teeny tiny section we're going to look
at a little section from x
to x plus delta x i'm just going to draw
a kind of a little picture over here
where we have some section of this
and i hope i've given myself enough
space here
from x
to
x plus
delta x
and this is a tiny little infinitesimal
section of my guitar string and we're
literally going to compute the forces
uh the masses and the acceleration on
this little section of string that's
vibrating we're going to make some
assumptions about what can be happening
and then we're going to to derive things
so what are the basic assumptions here
[Music]
the basic assumptions at least a couple
of the basic assumptions
are that
we're going to assume that gravity is
negligible
or gravity is negligible compared to the
tension in the string
gravity is negligible
negligible don't know how to spell
negligible
really compared to tension in the string
to string tension
good
uh which means we're gonna you know
tighten this guitar string up so that
when it's vibrating the vibration is
really only determined the motion is
only going to be these forces are only
from that string tension and gravity is
really negligible and you can kind of
convince yourself that this is true
because if you play guitar in kind of
the normal upright position it doesn't
matter if you play it this way or if you
play it this way or if you play it you
know if you rotate it in any plane it's
going to sound a bit about the same
because gravity has a negligible effect
on that guitar string
um what are some other assumptions some
other assumptions i'm going to make are
that the deflections even though i've
drawn a really big kind of cartoonishly
large deflection we're going to assume
that all of our our deflections are
small okay so deflections
deflections are kind of small
and this is going to allow us to make a
small angle approximation work so we're
going to assume that all of the kind of
angles throughout this path
are small and it's going to allow us to
make a very very important third
assumption
which is pretty much related which is
that the tension in this string is
constant
throughout the string we have basically
the same tension everywhere in the
string that's kind of how tension works
for small deflections
so tension
uh is the same
throughout
throughout
x okay so
at every x location i'm going to assume
that the tension in the string
is the same
and so so this is an important variable
to mention is that the tension we're
going to call this t and this is a force
okay so tension is literally a force in
that string
so there is a tension vector here
t
and there is a tension vector here t
and those are the same forces they have
the same kind of force t at the left
side of the segment and at the right
side of the segment
and
essentially what we're going to say is
that because i i again i drew this so
that it's not really a small angle
that's just for for visual uh to make it
visually easy to see
but what we're going to assume is that
these are small angles and so the kind
of x component are approximately equal
because cosine of those small angles are
about equal to one
and so there's not going to be any
horizontal motion of the segment there's
only going to be a vertical motion
because of the vertical components of
these two tensions being different and
causing an acceleration
so that's where the force is going to
come from is from the vertical component
of these two tensions at the left and
the right part of my segment
and the mass and the acceleration i'm
going to write down right now
so the mass
the mass
in this little segment we're going to
say is equal to rho
delta x
where rho
is essentially the density or let's say
the mass per unit length so this is
called the linear density
linear density
which is the mass
per length
and so this is you know already we're
going to start seeing that um you know a
thicker guitar string on the lower uh
for example e
string
is going to have a larger linear density
it's going to have more mass per length
than the the really small kind of higher
e string which is has a lower mass per
length so that's presumably going to
change kind of the wave speed and the
sound that those strings make
okay so this is kind of all that we need
to start building the solution now so
literally mass is rho times delta x
and so mass times acceleration
m a is just going to equal rho
delta x and in this case acceleration is
we're only talking about acceleration in
the vertical direction because that
guitar string is kind of you know
oscillating this way at least the way
that i'm oriented
and so a the acceleration in time
is just uh utt this is the second
derivative of u with respect to time the
first derivative is velocity the second
derivative is acceleration
um you know in in that vertical
displacement direction so mass times
acceleration is rho delta x utt
now i need to derive what my force is
equal to and i've already kind of
alluded
uh that my force is going to be from the
y components of these two tensions not
being equal because the angles are not
equal
and so that's what we're going to derive
now
so the force
in the y direction is going to be from
these tensions and i've seen this
derived a number of different ways and
you know i kind of have my own favorite
way but there's no right or wrong way
there's lots of ways of coming up with
the right answer
so what we're going to do is we're going
to call this angle here
theta
and we're going to call this angle let's
see if i have enough room here theta
plus
delta theta we're just going to kind of
define you know this angle here is theta
plus delta theta this angle is theta
and we're going to say that the force in
the y direction the force i care about
is um f
equals
and i'm going to define it so that you
know this one is pulling
in the you know kind of positive
direction this one's pulling in the
negative direction so minus t here plus
t here so the force is equal to t
only the vertical component so sine
of theta plus delta theta
minus
t times sine
of theta that's the force in the y
direction okay
and i could just take this expression
and say that equals rho delta x utt and
that's absolutely true that is newton's
second law that's conservation of
momentum
in this section of the string
but this expression here is not that
useful i want something that's u x x not
something in terms of theta so how do i
get this u x x from this expression here
and the way that i do that
is again using the small angle
approximation
um cosine of theta well so sine of theta
is just theta sine of theta plus delta
theta is just theta plus delta theta
and cosine of both of these are
approximately equal to one
so if i divided both of these by cosine
of those angles that would be basically
dividing them by one and so because of
this uh small deflections a small angle
approximation we can essentially say
that this is approximately equal to t
and now instead of sines i can just
replace these with tangents same
same deal doesn't it doesn't change
anything
so tan
theta plus delta uh
delta theta
that's a delta sorry
minus
tan
of theta okay so again just from the
small angle approximation this force is
now my tension times uh tan of this
angle minus tan of this angle
but the kind of cool thing is and i
think i picked this up um you know
watching watching another
lecture online and i hadn't realized
this since you know i guess i was a high
school student probably like it's
something you learn and then at least i
forgot it
is that tan of theta this is super cool
tan of theta of course is you know the
delta y over the delta x
but that delta y
is
is u so that's you know that's
essentially partial u
partial x so partial u partial x is tan
of theta
so this is essentially
um you know partial u
partial x evaluated at
x plus delta x
at time
minus partial u partial x evaluated at x
at my given time t i'm going to say this
one more time
we are you know we're saying that the
force that's accelerating this piece of
the string or the yeah the vibrating
string vertically
is the vertical component of this
minus the vertical component of this so
you know t sine theta plus theta dot
minus t sine theta
we can change those signs to tangents
because of a small angle approximation
and now tan of theta
is
essentially the the change of u with
respect to x partial u partial x partial
u partial x here minus partial u partial
x here
times tension is the force in that
spring the string this is the force in
that string
and so now what we're going to do is
we're going to take this expression for
force and this expression for mass times
acceleration and set them equal to each
other
so i'll do that now so i have
and i'm going to divide both sides by
rho delta x so i'm going to get u
t
equals this expression divided by rho
delta x so t
over rho delta x
times sorry this is a squeaky marker i
know it drives some people crazy
partial u partial x evaluated x plus
delta x at time t
minus partial u partial x
at x and t
and now
of course what we're going to do is
we're going to take the limit
as delta x goes to zero right we always
were assuming that this was going to be
an infinitesimal little section of of
string
uh of of uh yeah like a guitar string
and so now what we're going to do is
we're going to take the limit as delta x
goes to zero
and the limit as delta x goes to zero of
this expression divided by delta x is
just the derivative of partial u partial
x with respect to x
which is the second partial derivative
of u with respect to x i'm just going to
write this out this is uh maybe i'll
write it in pink
you know and so now what we're going to
do is we're going to take the limit as
delta x goes to 0
of t over rho
1 over delta x
uh you know partial u partial x
x plus delta x at time t minus partial u
partial x
x in time
and so the limit as as uh delta x goes
to zero of this expression here
is just you know the derivative of this
quantity of partial u partial x so
that's partial squared u partial x
squared so this thing here
is just u sub x x
you know which we're defining as partial
squared u
partial x squared
and so now what we have we have derived
the wave equation we're at the end where
u t t
u t t the second partial derivative of u
with respect to time this is the kind of
acceleration term
is equal to t over rho
times u x x
so this is
the wave equation
where
c squared equals t
over
rho okay the tension divided by the
linear density
so this is really cool um maybe i'll
just do like a super quick recap of how
i derived this um in a little bit but i
want to point out that this was um
you know essentially very intuitive so
now what we have is we have this this
wave equation
where the wave speed itself c squared
um the square of the wave speed is
directly related to the material
properties of that guitar string the
tension in the string and the linear
density okay so we'll we'll revisit this
in a little bit
um
and in the next lecture of course what
i'm going to do is we're going to
actually now solve this equation for
given boundary conditions so i'm going
to take again we're going to take the
guitar string
pinned between
x equals 0 and x equals l that's kind of
the length of the guitar string we're
going to pin it we're going to tension
it up you know so that we have some
tension and we're actually going to
solve this wave equation using the
separation of variables very very
powerful method
in partial differential equations my
last video
i just put out was all about separation
of variables
for partial differential equations for
laplace's equation for the heat equation
now we're going to do it for this wave
equation okay which is arguably even
more ubiquitous right the wave equation
is everywhere from optics
to guitar strings to uh acoustics right
let's say i'm on my slack line
and i'm whistling
you know the acoustic waves generated by
that are also
governed by this extremely important
uh wave equation a second order
hyperbolic partial differential equation
i'll tell you what i mean by hyperbolic
uh in a little bit i'm not this is not
just hyperbole
okay good um
so the quick quick recap of how we
solved uh or how we derived this wave
equation from scratch was that we
basically zoomed into a little
infinitesimal segment of our guitar
string so this is the guitar string here
it's a little tiny tiny segment um you
know from x to x plus delta x
we made some fairly simple assumptions
that the string is under enough tension
that gravity is negligible compared to
the tension so the dominant force is
from the string tension
we've made the assumption that the
deflections are relatively small
again so that you can use kind of a
small angle small theta approximation
even though i drew this with a really
exaggerated theta just to make it easy
to draw you know if you look at your
guitar string it's really not moving a
lot compared to the length l and so
these deflections are small
and those small deflections allow us to
make the uh further assumption that the
tension is relatively constant
throughout the string so the tension you
know at the end that you you twist you
know the little thumb screw to increase
the tension that sets the tension uh at
a constant level throughout that entire
guitar string even when the string is
moving
so given those assumptions you can
essentially write down force equals mass
times acceleration f equals m a on the
segment
and then by keeping careful track of
what all the forces are
and what all the accelerations and
masses are you can derive this wave
equation okay so remember f equals ma is
just conservation of momentum uh you
know you know concert in this case
vertical uh momentum of a little mass of
guitar string
so the mass is rho delta x because rho
is the linear density so you know that
linear density times delta x gives you
the total mass in that segment
the acceleration of that segment in the
vertical direction is
u tt the second derivative of u with
respect to time because u is its
vertical position
and so you know mass times acceleration
is kind of the easy part to derive
the force i mean it's not really that
much harder you take the the tension
force which are always tangential i
guess that's another assumption i should
have made that's kind of an obvious one
is that the tension is always tangent uh
to the you know the curvature of that
string
and so basically the fact that the
string is bending throughout this little
uh delta x segment means that the
vertical component of my force on the
left side is not exactly equal to the
vertical component of the force on my
right side and there is some net
vertical force accelerating uh this
little bit of string up and down
that little net vertical bit of force is
given by t
sine of theta plus theta delta
theta minus t sine theta
the vertical force on the right hand
side minus the vertical force on the
left-hand side okay we're also of course
assuming because of this small angle
approximation that the cosine components
the kind of x components of these two
forces are very very nearly equal to
each other and equal to one because
cosine of a small angle equals cosine of
this other small angle equals one we
assume that there is kind of no net
force moving this thing in the in the x
direction just in the y direction
okay so our small angle approximation
then goes into this tangent you can
basically turn these signs into tangents
because again dividing by cosine doesn't
do anything for small angles
and then we use this kind of neat little
trick that tan of theta is equal to
partial u partial x it's literally you
know whatever delta
in the vertical direction which is my my
u variable delta u delta x and if i take
that limit i get partial u partial x
and so now when i combine this force
with this mass times acceleration into
one equation
and i take the limit as my delta x goes
to zero i recover that this uh this
force component here has to equal uxx my
force is proportional to the second
derivative of u with respect to x which
is another way of saying the curvature
of the string in uh kind of with respect
to that x uh
variable this is the curvature
of the string so higher curvatures kind
of a sharper bend is going to be a much
bigger force that's going to accelerate
my strength that makes sense because my
string doesn't want to be really you
know tightly bent around a very very
sharp point of curvature
okay and that's how we derived this
equation
so last thing i'm going to do in this
lecture you know in the next lecture
we're going to solve this thing with
separation of variables last thing i'm
going to do in this lecture
is revisit
the guitar string
and so i want to think about if it makes
physical sense
that you know how the tension changes
things and how the linear density
changes things
so what i would expect
is that increasing the tension t
should increase
the speed the wave speed c so if i you
know if i take
my low e
and i increase the tension
[Music]
am i on the wrong one i'm on the wrong
string
okay now you can hear it i'm increasing
the tension
you can hear it's increasing that wave
speed now i haven't directly shown you
this is something i'll show you in the
next lecture when we solve this using
separation of variables remember when
this string vibrates
the string itself is governed by the the
wave equation but it's also oscillating
the air and creating these acoustic
waves which are also governed by the
wave equation and so kind of
as you know
as the speed of information travels
through this this guitar string what i'm
going to show you
is that uh kind of the
the vibrational frequency also depends
on this uh c quantity here it also
depends on the length which is why
having a longer string would make this a
lower frequency and having a shorter
string would make it a higher frequency
okay good so increasing the tension
makes it a higher pitch
decreasing the tension
makes it a lower pitch a lower
wave speed
okay now let's talk about the linear
density
so the linear density is literally you
know how much mass there is per unit
length of string
so my thicker strings
have a
a higher linear density a larger linear
density than my smaller string
just literally because it has a smaller
cross sectional the smaller string is a
small cross-sectional area it weighs
less per centimeter than my larger
string
and so what that means is that my larger
string has a big row and so dividing by
a big number makes c
lower so my
my big string
has a lower wave speed than my small
string
assuming that they're made of the same
material you know let's say they're both
made of metal the same metal
now another way that you can change this
and that's actually how how these
strings are
is that the three uh lower strings are
made out of metal and the three higher
strings
are made out of nylon and so the nylon
also has a lower linear density so
that's another way to make this number
smaller the lower linear density for
those those higher strings
which makes them you know higher pitch
higher
wave speed but without making them teeny
tiny so if you want your strings to be
you know just the same thickness but
still be higher pitched you can make
them out of a lighter material like
nylon okay
so these are all kind of cool outfalls
directly of you know the f equals ma
physics that went into deriving this
wave equation for this vibrating guitar
string
okay so in the next lecture we're going
to solve this thing using uh separation
of variables we're going to still you
know look at how that guitar string
vibrates we're going to look at how the
sound will change as we change things
like
the length of that guitar string you
know these material properties i'm going
to revisit this once we you know
actually look at the solution of this
wave equation
and we're going to do that using
separation of variables this is probably
for me you know one of my favorite new
lectures because it took me you know a
long time to feel comfortable with this
derivation and the solution but now that
i do it really is kind of a piece of
cake okay so i hope you find this uh as
interesting and as fun and as you know
widely applicable
as i do all right stay tuned thanks